The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: --124.
If I were to repeat
this 1,000 times,
so every one of
those 1,000 times
they collect 124
data points and then
I'd do it again and
do it again and again,
then in average, the
number I should get
should be close to the true
parameter that I'm looking for.
The fluctuations that
are due to the fact
that I get different
samples every time
should somewhat vanish.
And so what I want is to have a
small bias, hopefully a 0 bias.
If this thing is 0, then we see
that the estimator is unbiased.
So this is definitely
a property that we
are going to be looking
for in an estimator,
trying to find them
to be unbiased.
But we'll see that it's
actually maybe not enough.
So unbiasedness should
not be something
you lose your sleep over.
Something that's slightly
better is the risk, really
the quadratics risk,
which is expectation of--
so if I have an
estimator, theta hat,
I'm going to look at the
expectation of theta hat n
minus theta squared.
And what we showed last time
is that we can actually--
by inserting in there,
adding and removing
the expectation of
theta hat, we actually
get something where
this thing can
be decomposed as the square
of the bias plus the variance,
which is just the expectation of
theta hat minus its expectation
squared.
That came from
the fact that when
I added and removed the
expectation of theta hat
in there, the
cross-terms cancel.
All right.
So that was the bias squared,
and this is the variance.
And so for example, if the
quadratic risk goes to 0,
then that means that
theta hat converges
to theta in the L2 sense.
And here we know that if
we want this to go to 0,
since it's the sum of
two positive terms,
we need to have both
the bias that goes to 0
and the variance
that goes to 0, so we
need to control both
of those things.
And so there is usually
an inherent trade-off
between getting a small bias
and getting a small variance.
If you reduce one too much, then
the variance of the other one
is going to--
then the other one is going
to increase, or the opposite.
That happens a lot, but not so
much, actually, in this class.
So let's just look at
a couple of examples.
So am I planning--
yeah.
So examples.
So if I do, for example, X1,
Xn, there are iid Bernoulli.
And I'm going to
write it theta so
that we keep the same notation.
Then theta hat, what
is the theta hat
that we proposed many times?
It's just X bar, Xn bar,
the average of Xi's.
So what is the bias of this guy?
Well, to know the bias, I
just have to remove theta
from the expectation.
What is the
expectation of Xn bar?
Well, by linearity
of the expectation,
it's just the average
of the expectations.
But since all my Xi's are
Bernouilli with the same theta,
then each of this guy is
actually equal to theta.
So this thing is actually
theta, which means
that this isn't biased, right?
Now, what is the
variance of this guy?
So if you forgot the
properties of the variance
for sum of independent
random variables,
now it's time to wake up.
So we have the
variance of something
that looks like 1 over n, the
sum from i equal 1 to n of Xi.
So it's of the form
variance of a constant times
a random variable.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is pull out the constant.
But we know that the variance
leaves on the square scale,
so when I pull out a constant
outside of the variance,
it comes out with a square.
The variance of a
times X is a-squared
times the variance of
X, so this is equal to 1
over n squared times
the variance of the sum.
So now we want to always
do what we want to do.
So we have the
variance of the sum.
We would like somehow
to say that this
is the sum of the variances.
And in general, we are
not allowed to say that,
but we are because my Xi's
are actually independent.
So this is actually equal to 1
over n squared sum from i equal
1 to n of the variance
of each of the Xi's.
And that's by independence,
so this is basic probability.
And now, what is the variance
of Xi's where again they're
all the same distribution,
so the variance of Xi
is the same as the
variance of X1.
And so each of those
guys has variance what?
What is the variance
of a Bernoulli?
We've said it once.
It's theta times 1 minus theta.
And so now I'm going to have
the sum of n times a constant,
so I get n times the constant
divided by n squared,
so one of the n's
is going to cancel.
And so the whole
thing here is actually
equal to theta, 1 minus
theta divided by n.
So if I'm interested
in the quadratic risk--
and again, I should
just say risk,
because this is the
only risk we're going
to be actually looking at.
Yeah.
This parenthesis should
really stop here.
I really wanted to put
quadratic in parenthesis.
So the risk of this guy is what?
Well, it's the expectation of
x bar n minus theta squared.
And we know it's the
square of the variance,
so it's the square
of the bias, which
we know is 0, so it's 0 squared
plus the variance, which
is theta, 1 plus theta--
1 minus theta divided by n.
So it's just theta, 1
minus theta divided by n.
So this is just summarizing the
performance of an estimator,
which is the random variable.
I mean, it's complicated.
If I really wanted
to describe it,
I would just tell you
the entire distribution
of this random variable.
But now what I'm doing
is I'm saying, well,
let's just take this random
variable, remove theta from it,
and see how small the
fluctuations around theta--
the squared fluctuations around
theta are in expectation.
So that's what the
quadratic risk is doing.
And in a way, this
decomposition,
as the sum of the bias
square and the variance,
is really telling you that--
it is really accounting for
the bias, which is, well,
even if I had an infinite
amount of observations,
is this thing doing
the right thing?
And the other thing is
actually the variance,
so for finite number
of observations,
what are the fluctuations?
All right.
Then you can see that those
things, bias and variance,
are actually very different.
So I don't have any
colors here, so you're
going to have to really
follow the speed--
the order in which
I draw those curves.
All right.
So let's find--
I'm going to give you three
candidate estimators, so--
estimators for theta.
So the first one is
definitely Xn bar.
That will be a good
candidate estimator.
The second one is going to
be 0.5, because after all,
why should I bother if
it's actually going to be--
right?
So for example, if
I ask you to predict
the score of some
candidate in some election,
then since you know it's
going to be very close to 0.5,
you might as well just throw
0.5 and you're not going
to be very far from reality.
And it's actually going
to cost you 0 time and $0
to come up with that.
So sometimes maybe
just a good old guess
is actually doing
the job for you.
Of course, for
presidential elections
or something like this,
it's not very helpful
if your prediction
is telling you this.
But if it was
something different,
that would be a good way to
generate some close to 1/2.
For a coin, for example,
if I give you a coin,
you never know.
Maybe it's slightly biased.
But the good guess, just
looking at it, inspecting it,
maybe there's something
crazy happening
with the structure
of it, you're going
to guess that it's 0.5 without
trying to collect information.
And let's find another one,
which is, well, you know,
I have a lot of observations.
But I'm recording couples
kissing, but I'm on a budget.
I don't have time to
travel all around the world
and collect some people.
So really, I'm just going
to look at the first couple
and go home.
So my other estimator
is just going to be X1.
I just take the first
observation, 0, 1,
and that's it.
So now I'm going--
I want to actually understand
what the behavior of those guys
is.
All right.
So we know-- and so we know
that for this guy, the bias is 0
and the variance
is equal to theta,
1 minus theta divided by n.
What is the bias
of this guy, 0.5?
AUDIENCE: 0.5.
AUDIENCE: 0.5 minus theta?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 0.5
minus theta, right.
So the bias, 0.5 minus theta.
What is the variance
of this guy?
What is the variance of 0.5?
AUDIENCE: It's 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 0.
Right.
It's just a
deterministic number,
so there's no
fluctuations for this guy.
What is the bias?
Well, X1 is actually--
just for simplicity,
I can think of it
as being X1 bar, the
average of itself,
so that wherever I saw an n for
this guy, I can replace it by 1
and that will give
me my formula.
So the bias is
still going to be 0.
And the variance is going to be
equal to theta, 1 minus theta.
So now I have those
three estimators.
Well, if I compare
X1 and Xn bar, then
clearly I have 0
bias in both cases.
That's good.
And I have the variance that's
actually n times smaller when I
use my n observations
than when I don't.
So those two guys,
on these two fronts,
you can actually look
at the two numbers
and say, well, the first
number is the same.
The second number is
better for the other guy,
so I will definitely go for
this guy compared to this guy.
So this guy is gone.
But not this guy.
Well, if I look at the
bias, the variance is 0.
It's always beating the
variance of this guy.
And if I look at the bias, it's
actually really not that bad.
It's 0.5 minus theta.
In particular, if theta
is 0.5, then this guy
is strictly better.
And so you can actually
now look at what
the quadratic risk looks like.
So here, what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to take my
true theta-- so it's
going to range between 0 and 1.
And we know that those two
things are functions of theta,
so I can only understand
them if I plot them
as functions of theta.
And so now I'm going
to actually plot--
the y-axis is going
to be the risk.
So what is the risk of
the estimator of 0.5?
This one is easy.
Well, it's 0 plus the
square of 0.5 minus theta.
So we know that at theta,
it's actually going to be 0.
And then it's going
to be a square.
So at 0, it's going to be 0.25.
And at 1, it's going
to be 0.25 as well.
So it looks like this.
Well, actually, sorry.
Let me put the 0.5
where it should be.
OK.
So this here is the risk of 0.5.
And we'll write it like this.
So when theta is very close
to 0.5, I'm very happy.
When theta gets farther,
it's a little bit annoying.
And then here, I want to
plot the risk of this guy.
So now the thing with
the risk of this guy
is that it will depend on n.
So I will just pick some
n that I'm happy with just
so that I can
actually draw a curve.
Otherwise, I'm going to have to
plot one curve per value of n.
So let's just say, for
example, that n is equal to 10.
And so now I need to plot
the function theta, 1 minus
theta divided by 10.
We know that theta,
1 minus theta
is a curve that goes like this.
It takes value at 1/2.
It thinks value 1/4.
That's the maximum.
And then it's 0 at the end.
So really, if n is
equal to 1, this
is what the variance looks like.
The bias doesn't
count in the risk.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Sure.
Can you move?
All right.
Are you guys good?
So now I have this picture.
And I know I'm going up to 25.
And there's a place
where those curves cross.
So if you're sure--
let's say you're talking
about presidential election,
you know that those things
are going to be really close.
Maybe you're actually
better by predicting 0.5
if you know it's not
going to go too far.
But that's for one observation,
so that's the risk of X1.
But if I look at the
risk of Xn, all I'm doing
is just crushing
this curve down to 0.
So as n increases, it's going
to look more and more like this.
It's the same
curve divided by n.
And so now I can just
start to understand
that for different
values of thetas,
now I'm going to have to be very
close to theta is equal to 1/2
if I want to start saying
that Xn bar is worse
than the naive estimator 0.5.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I know you explained a little
bit before, but can you just--
what is an intuitive
definition of risk?
What is it actually describing?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So either you can--
well, when you have an unbiased
estimator, it's simple.
It's just telling you
it's the variance,
because the theta that you
have over there is really-- so
in the definition of
the risk, the theta
that you have here
if you're unbiased
is really the
expectation of theta hat.
So that's really
just the variance.
So the risk is
really telling you
how much fluctuations I
have around my expectation
if unbiased.
But actually here, it's telling
you how much fluctuations
I have in average around theta.
So if you understand the
notion of variance as being--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: What?
AUDIENCE: Like
variance on average.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No.
AUDIENCE: No.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It's
just like variance.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So when you--
I mean, if you claim you
understand what variance is,
it's telling you
what is the expected
squared fluctuation
around the expectation
of my random variable.
It's just telling you on
average how far I'm going to be.
And you take the square because
you want to cancel the signs.
Otherwise, you're
going to get 0.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: And
here it's saying, well,
I really don't care what the
expectation of theta hat is.
What I want to get
to is theta, so I'm
looking at the expectation
of the squared fluctuations
around theta itself.
If I'm unbiased, it
coincides with the variance.
But if I'm biased, then I
have to account for the fact
that I'm really
not computing the--
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK.
Thanks.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK?
All right.
Are there any questions?
So here, what I really
want to illustrate
is that the risk
itself is a function
of theta most of the times.
And so for different
thetas, some estimators
are going to be
better than others.
But there's also
the entire range
of estimators, those
that are really biased,
but the bias can
completely vanish.
And so here, you see
you have no bias,
but the variance can be large.
Or you have 0 bias--
you have a bias, but
the variance is 0.
So you can actually
have this trade-off
and you can find things that are
in the entire range in general.
So those things are
actually-- those trade-offs
between bias and variance are
usually much better illustrated
if we're talking about
multivariate parameters.
If I actually look
at a parameter which
is the mean of some multivariate
Gaussian, so an entire vector,
then the bias is going to--
I can make the bias
bigger by, for example,
forcing all the coordinates of
my estimator to be the same.
So here, I'm going
to get some bias,
but the variance
is actually going
to be much better, because
I get to average all
the coordinates for this guy.
And so really, the
bias/variance trade-off
is when you have multiple
parameters to estimate,
so you have a vector
of parameters,
a multivariate
parameter, the bias
increases when you're trying
to pull more information
across the different
components to actually have
a lower variance.
So the more you average,
the lower the variance.
That's exactly what
we've illustrated.
As n increases, the
variance decreases,
like 1 over n or theta,
1 minus theta over n.
And so this is how it
happens in general.
In this class, it's mostly
one-dimensional parameter
estimation, so it's going to be
a little harder to illustrate
that.
But if you do, for example,
non-parametric estimation,
that's all you do.
There's just bias/variance
trade-offs all the time.
And in between, when you have
high-dimensional parametric
estimation, that
happens a lot as well.
OK.
So I'm just going to go quickly
through those two remaining
slides, because we've
actually seen them.
But I just wanted you to have
somewhere a formal definition
of what a confidence
interval is.
And so we fixed a statistical
model for n observations, X1
to Xn.
The parameter theta
here is one-dimensional.
Theta is a subset
of the real line,
and that's why I
talk about intervals.
An interval is a
subset of the line.
If I had a subset
of R2, for example,
that would no longer be called
an interval, but a region,
just because-- well, that's
just we can say a set,
a confidence set.
But people like to
say confidence region.
So an interval is just a
one-dimensional conference
region.
And it has to be an
interval as well.
So a confidence interval
of level 1 minus alpha--
so we refer to the quality
of a confidence interval
is actually called it's level.
It takes value 1 minus alpha
for some positive alpha.
And so the confidence level--
the level of the confidence
interval is between 0 and 1.
The closer to 1 it is, the
better the confidence interval.
The closer to 0,
the worse it is.
And so for any
random interval-- so
a confidence interval
is a random interval.
The bounds of this interval
depends on random data.
Just like we had
X bar plus/minus
1 over square root of
n, for example, or 2
over square root
of n, this X bar
was the random thing that would
make fluctuate those guys.
And so now I have an interval.
And now I have its boundaries,
but now the boundaries
are not allowed to depend
on my unknown parameter.
Otherwise, it's not a
confidence interval,
just like an
estimator that depends
on the unknown parameter
is not an estimator.
The confidence interval
has to be something
that I can compute
once I collect data.
And so what I want is that--
so there's this weird notation.
The fact that I write theta--
that's the probability
that I contains theta.
You're used to seeing
theta belongs to I.
But here, I really
want to emphasize
that the randomness is
in I. And so the way
you actually say
it when you read
this formula is the probability
that I contains theta
is at least 1 minus alpha.
So it better be close to 1.
You want 1 minus alpha
to be very close to 1,
because it's really
telling you that whatever
random variable I'm giving
you, my error bars are actually
covering the right theta.
And I want this to be true.
But I want this--
since I don't know
what my confidence--
my parameter of theta
is, I want this to hold
true for all possible values
of the parameters that nature
may have come up with from.
So I want this-- so there's
theta that changes here,
so the distribution
of the interval
is actually changing
with theta hopefully.
And theta is changing
with this guy.
So regardless of the value
of theta that I'm getting,
I want that the probability
that it contains the theta
is actually larger
than 1 minus alpha.
So I'll come back
to it in a second.
I just want to say
that here, we can
talk about asymptotic level.
And that's typically when
you use central limit
theorem to compute this guy.
Then you're not guaranteed
that the value is
at least 1 minus
alpha for every n,
but it's actually in the limit
larger than 1 minus alpha.
So maybe for each fixed n
it's going to be not true.
But for as no goes
to infinity, it's
actually going to become true.
If you want this to
hold for every n,
you actually need to use things
such as Hoeffding's inequality
that we described at some
point, that hold for every n.
So as a rule of thumb, if you
use the central limit theorem,
you're dealing with
a confidence interval
with asymptotic
level 1 minus alpha.
And the reason is
because you actually
want to get the quintiles
of the normal-- the Gaussian
distribution that comes from
the central limit theorem.
And if you want to use
Hoeffding's, for example,
you might actually get away with
a confidence interval that's
actually true even
non-asymptotically.
It's just the regular
confidence interval.
So this is the
formal definition.
It's a bit of a mouthful.
But we actually-- the best
way to understand them
is to build them.
Now, at some point I said--
and I think it was
part of the homework--
so here, I really
say the probability
the true parameter belongs
to the confidence interval
is actually 1 minus alpha.
And so that's because here,
this confidence interval
is still a random variable.
Now, if I start plugging
in numbers instead
of the random
variables X1 to Xn,
I start putting 1,
0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 1,
like I did for the kiss
example, then in this case,
the random interval is actually
going to be 0.42, 0.65.
And this guy, the probability
that theta belongs to it
is not 1 minus alpha.
It's either 0 if
it's not in there
or it's 1 if it's in there.
So here is the
example that we had.
So just let's look at back into
our favorite example, which
is the average of
Bernoulli random variables,
so we studied that maybe
that's the third time already.
So the sample average, Xn
bar, is a strongly consistent
estimator of p.
That was one of the
properties that we wanted.
Strongly consistent means
that as n goes to infinity,
it converges almost surely
to the true parameter.
That's the strong
law of large number.
It is consistent also, because
it's strongly consistent,
so it also converges
in probability,
which makes it consistent.
It's unbiased.
We've seen that.
We've actually computed
its quadratic risk.
And now what I have
is that if I look at--
thanks to the central limit
theorem, we actually did this.
We built a confidence interval
at level 1 minus alpha--
asymptotic level, sorry,
asymptotic level 1 minus alpha.
And so here, this
is how we did it.
Let me just go through it again.
So we know from the
central limit theorem--
so the central limit
theorem tells us
that Xn bar minus p divided
by square root of p1 minus p,
square root of n converges
in distribution as n
goes to infinity to some
standard normal distribution.
So what it means is that if
I look at the probability
under the true p, that's
square root of n, Xn bar
minus p divided by square
root of p1 minus p,
it's less than Q alpha
over 2, where this is
the definition of the quintile.
Then this guy-- and I'm actually
going to use the same notation,
limit as n goes to infinity,
this is the same thing.
So this is actually going to
be equal to 1 minus alpha.
That's exactly what
I did last time.
This is by definition of the
quintile of a standard Gaussian
and of a limit in distribution.
So the probabilities computed on
this guy in the limit converges
to the probability
computed on this guy.
And we know that this
is just the probability
that the absolute
value of sum n 0, 1
is less than Q alpha over 2.
And so in particular,
if it's equal,
then I can put some
larger than or equal to,
which guarantees my
asymptotic confidence level.
And I just solve for p.
So this is equivalent
to the limit
as n goes to infinity
of the probability
that theta is between
Xn bar minus Q
alpha over 2 divided by--
times square root of p1 minus p
divided by square root of n, Xn
bar plus q alpha over 2,
square root of p1 minus p
divided by square root of
n is larger than or equal
to 1 minus alpha.
And so there you go.
I have my confidence interval.
Except that's not, right?
We just said that the bounds
of a confidence interval
may not depend on the
unknown parameter.
And here, they do.
And so we actually
came up with two ways
of getting rid of this.
Since we only need this thing--
so this thing, as we said,
is really equal.
Every time I'm going to
make this guy smaller
and this guy larger,
I'm only going
to increase the probability.
And so what we do is
we actually just take
the largest possible
value for p1 minus
p, which makes the interval
as large as possible.
And so now I have this.
I just do one of the two tricks.
I replace p1 minus p by their
upper bound, which is 1/4.
As we said, p1 minus p, the
function looks like this.
So I just take the
value here at 1/2.
Or, I can use Slutsky and say
that if I replace p by Xn bar,
that's the same as just
replacing p by Xn bar here.
And by Slutsky, we know that
this is actually converging
also to some standard Gaussian.
We've seen that when we
saw Slutsky as an example.
And so those two
things-- actually,
just because I'm
taking the limit
and I'm only caring about the
asymptotic confidence level,
I can actually just plug in
consistent quantities in there,
such as Xn bar where
I don't have a p.
And that gives me another
confidence interval.
All right.
So this by now, hopefully
after doing it three times,
you should really, really be
comfortable with just creating
this confidence interval.
We did it three times in class.
I think you probably did
it another couple times
in your homework.
So just make sure you're
comfortable with this.
All right.
That's one of the basic
things you would want to know.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So Slutsky holds
for any single response set p.
But Xn converges [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
that's not Slutsky, right?
AUDIENCE: That's [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So Slutsky
tells you that if you--
Slutsky's about combining
two types of convergence.
So Slutsky tells you
that if you actually
have one Xn that converges
to X in distribution and Yn
that converges to Y
in probability, then
you can actually
multiply Xn and Yn
and get that the
limit in distribution
is the product of X and Y,
where X is now a constant.
And here we have the
constant, which is 1.
But I did that already, right?
Using Slutsky to
replace it for the--
to replace P by
Xn bar, we've done
that last time, maybe a
couple of times ago, actually.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I guess these
statements are [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So could we like
figure out [INAUDIBLE]
can we set a finite [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So of
course, the short answer is no.
So here's how you
would go about thinking
about which method is better.
So there's always the
more conservative method.
The first one, the only
thing you're losing
is the rate of convergence
of the central limit theorem.
So if n is large enough so
that the central limit theorem
approximation is very good,
then that's all you're
going to be losing.
Of course, the price you pay is
that your confidence interval
is wider than it
would be if you were
to use Slutsky for this
particular problem,
typically wider.
Actually, it is always
wider, because Xn bar--
1 minus Xn bar is always
less than 1/4 as well.
And so that's the
first thing you--
so Slutsky basically adds your
relying on the central limit--
your relying on the
asymptotics again.
Now of course, you don't
want to be conservative,
because you actually want to
squeeze as much from your data
as you can.
So it depends on how comfortable
and how critical it is for you
to put valid error bars.
If they're valid
in the asymptotics,
then maybe you're actually
going to go with Slutsky
so it actually gives you
slightly narrower confidence
intervals and so you feel
like you're a little more--
you have a more precise answer.
Now, if you really need
to be super-conservative,
then you're actually going
to go with the P1 minus P.
Actually, if you need to
be even more conservative,
you are going to go with
Hoeffding's so you don't even
have to rely on the
asymptotics level at all.
But then you're
confidence interval
becomes twice as wide
and twice as wide
and it becomes wider
and wider as you go.
So depends on--
I mean, there's a lot
of data in statistics
which is gauging how critical
it is for you to output
valid error bounds or if
they're really just here
to be indicative of the
precision of the estimator you
gave from a more
qualitative perspective.
AUDIENCE: So the error
there is [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
So here, there's basically
a bunch of errors.
There's one that's-- so there's
a theorem called Berry-Esseen
that quantifies how far this
probability is from 1 minus
alpha, but the
constants are terrible.
So it's not very
helpful, but it tells you
as n grows how smaller
this thing grows--
becomes smaller.
And then for
Slutsky, again you're
multiplying something that
converges by something that
fluctuates around 1, so
you need to understand
how this thing fluctuates.
Now, there's something
that shows up.
Basically, what is the
slope of the function 1
over square root of X1
minus X around the value
you're interested in?
And so if this function
is super-sharp,
then small fluctuations of Xn
bar around this expectation
are going to lead to
really high fluctuations
of the function itself.
So if you're looking at--
if you have f of Xn bar and
f around say the true P,
if f is really sharp
like that, then
if you move a little
bit here, then you're
going to move really
a lot on the y-axis.
So that's what the function
here-- the function
you're interested in is 1 over
square root of X1 minus X.
So what does this function look
like around the point where you
think P is the true parameter?
Its derivative really
is what matters.
OK?
Any other question.
OK.
So it's important,
because now we're
going to switch to the
real let's do some hardcore
computation type of things.
All right.
So in this chapter, we're
going to talk about maximum
likelihood estimation.
Who has already seen maximum
likelihood estimation?
OK.
And who knows what a
convex function is?
OK.
So we'll do a little bit of
reminders on those things.
So those things are when we do
maximum likelihood estimation,
likelihood is the function, so
we need to maximize a function.
That's basically
what we need to do.
And if I give you
a function, you
need to know how to
maximize this function.
Sometimes, you have
closed-form solutions.
You can take the derivative and
set it equal to 0 and solve it.
But sometimes, you actually
need to resort to algorithms
to do that.
And there's an entire
industry doing that.
And we'll briefly touch upon
it, but this is definitely
not the focus of this class.
OK.
So before diving directly
into the definition
of the likelihood and
what is the definition
of the maximum likelihood
estimator, what
I'm going to try to
do is to give you
an insight for what we're
actually doing when we do
maximum likelihood estimation.
So remember, we have a
model on a sample space E
and some candidate
distributions P theta.
And really, your goal is
to estimate a true theta
star, the one that generated
some data, X1 to Xn,
in an iid fashion.
But this theta star is
really a proxy for us
to know that we
actually understand
the distribution itself.
The goal of knowing theta star
is so that you can actually
know what P theta star.
Otherwise, it has--
well, sometimes we
said it has some meaning
itself, but really you
want to know what
the distribution is.
And so your goal is to actually
come up with the distribution--
hopefully that comes
from the family P theta--
that's close to P theta star.
So in a way, what does it mean
to have two distributions that
are close?
It means that when you
compute probabilities
on one distribution,
you should have
the same probability on the
other distribution pretty much.
So what we can do
is say, well, now I
have two candidate
distributions.
So if theta hat leads to a
candidate distribution P theta
hat, and this is
the true theta star,
it leads to the true
distribution P theta star
according to which
my data was drawn.
That's my candidate.
As a statistician, I'm
supposed to come up
with a good candidate,
and this is the truth.
And what I want is that
if you actually give me
the distribution,
then I want when
I'm computing
probabilities for this guy,
I know what the probabilities
for the other guys are.
And so really what I want is
that if I compute a probability
under theta hat of
some interval a, b,
it should be pretty
close to the probability
under theta star of a, b.
And more generally,
if I want to take
the union of two intervals,
I want this to be true.
If I take just 1/2 lines, I
want this to be true from 0
to infinity, for example,
things like this.
I want this to be true
for all of them at once.
And so what I do is that I
write A for a probability event.
And I want that P hat of
A is close to P star of A
for any event A in
the sample space.
Does that sound like
a reasonable goal
for a statistician?
So in particular, if I
want those to be close,
I want the absolute
value of their difference
to be close to 0.
And this turns out to be--
if I want this to hold
for all possible A's, I
have all possible events, so I'm
going to actually maximize over
these events.
And I'm going to
look at the worst
possible event on which theta
hat can depart from theta star.
And so rather than
defining it specifically
for theta hat and
theta star, I'm
just going to say, well, if
you give me two probability
measures, P theta
and P theta prime,
I want to know how
close they are.
Well, if I want to
measure how close they
are by how they can
differ when I measure
the probability
of some event, I'm
just looking at the absolute
value of the difference
of the probabilities
and I'm just
maximizing over the worst
possible event that might
actually make them differ.
Agreed?
That's a pretty strong notion.
So if the total variation
between theta and theta prime
is small, it means that for all
possible A's that you give me,
then P theta of A is
going to be close to P
theta prime of A, because if--
let's say I just found the
bound on the total variation
distance, which is 0.01.
All right.
So that means that this
is going to be larger
than the max over A of P theta
minus P theta prime of A,
which means that for any A--
actually, let me write P
theta hat and P theta star,
like we said, theta
hat and theta star.
And so if I have a bound,
say, on the total variation,
which is 0.01, that
means that P theta hat--
every time I compute a
probability on P theta hat,
it's basically in the
interval P theta star of A,
the one that I really wanted
to compute, plus or minus 0.01.
This has nothing to do
with confidence interval.
This is just
telling me how far I
am from the value of
actually trying to compute.
And that's true for
all A. And that's key.
That's where this
max comes into play.
It just says, I want
this bound to hold
for all possible A's at once.
So this is actually a
very well-known distance
between probability measures.
It's the total
variation distance.
It's extremely central to
probabilistic analysis.
And it essentially tells
you that every time--
if two probability
distributions are close,
then it means that every
time I compute a probability
under P theta but
I really actually
have data from P
theta prime, then
the error is no larger
than the total variation.
OK.
So this is maybe not
the most convenient way
of finding a distance.
I mean, how are you going--
in reality, how are you
to compute this maximum
over all possible events?
I mean, it's just crazy, right?
There's an infinite
number of them.
It's much larger than the number
of intervals, for example,
so it's a bit annoying.
And so there's actually
a way to compress it
by just looking at the basically
function distance or vector
distance between probability
mass functions or probability
density functions.
So I'm going to start
with the discrete version
of the total variation.
So throughout this
chapter, I will
make the difference between
discrete random variables
and continuous random variables.
It really doesn't matter.
All it means is that when
I talk about discrete,
I will talk about
probability mass functions.
And when I talk
about continuous,
I will talk about probability
density functions.
When I talk about
probability mass functions,
I talk about sums.
When I talk about probability
density functions,
I talk about integrals.
But they're all the
same thing, really.
So let's start with the
probability mass function.
Everybody remembers what
the probability mass
function of a discrete
random variable is.
This is the function that tells
me for each possible value
that it can take,
the probability
that it takes this value.
So the Probability
Mass Function, PMF,
is just the function for
all x in the sample space
tells me the probability
that my random variable is
equal to this little value.
And I will denote it
by P sub theta of X.
So what I want is, of
course, that the sum
of the probabilities is 1.
And I want them to
be non-negative.
Actually, typically we will
assume that they are positive.
Otherwise, we can just remove
this x from the sample space.
And so then I have the total
variation distance, I mean,
it's supposed to be the
maximum overall sets of--
of subsets of E, such
that the probability
of A minus probability
of theta prime of A--
it's complicated,
but really there's
this beautiful
formula that tells me
that if I look at the total
variation between P theta
and P theta prime, it's
actually equal to just 1/2
of the sum for all X in E of the
absolute difference between P
theta X and P theta prime of X.
So that's something
you can compute.
If I give you two
probability mass functions,
you can compute
this immediately.
But if I give you
just the densities
and the original distribution,
the original definition
where you have to max
over all possible events,
it's not clear
you're going to be
able to do that very quickly.
So this is really the
one you can work with.
But the other one is
really telling you
what it is doing for you.
It's controlling the
difference of probabilities
you can compute on any event.
But here, it's just
telling you, well,
if you do it for each
simple event, it's little x.
It's actually simple.
Now, if we have continuous
random variables-- so
by the way, I didn't mention,
but discrete means Bernoulli.
Binomial, but not only those
that have finite support,
like Bernoulli has
support of size 2,
binomial NP has
support of size n--
there's n possible values it
can take-- but also Poisson.
Poisson distribution can
take an infinite number
of values, all the
positive integers,
non-negative integers.
And so now we have also
the continuous ones,
such as Gaussian, exponential.
And what characterizes
those guys is that they
have a probability density.
So the density,
remember the way I
use my density is
when I want to compute
the probability of
belonging to some event A.
The probability of X falling to
some subset of the real line A
is simply the integral of
the density on this set.
That's the famous area
under the curve thing.
So since for each possible
value, the probability at X--
so I hope you
remember that stuff.
That's just probably
something that you
must remember from probability.
But essentially, we know that
the probability that X is equal
to little x is 0 for a
continuous random variable,
for all possible X's.
There's just none of them
that actually gets weight.
So what we have to do is to
describe the fact that it's
in some little region.
So the probability that it's in
some interval, say, a, b, this
is the integral between A
and B of f theta of X, dx.
So I have this density,
such as the Gaussian one.
And the probability that I
belong to the interval a,
b is just the area under
the curve between A and B.
If you don't remember that,
please take immediate remedy.
So this function f, just
like P, is non-negative.
And rather than summing
to 1, it integrates to 1
when I integrate it over
the entire sample space E.
And now the total
variation, well, it
takes basically the same form.
I said that you
essentially replace sums
by integrals when you're
dealing with densities.
And here, it's just
saying, rather than having
1/2 of the sum of
the absolute values,
you have 1/2 of the integral
of the absolute value
of the difference.
Again, if I give
you two densities
and if you're not too bad at
calculus, which you will often
be, because there's lots of them
you can actually not compute.
But if I gave you, for example,
two Gaussian densities,
exponential minus x squared,
blah, blah, blah, and I say,
just compute the total
variation distance,
you could actually
write it as an integral.
Now, whether you can
actually reduce this integral
to some particular
number is another story.
But you could technically do it.
So now, you have actually
a handle on this thing
and you could technically
ask Mathematica,
whereas asking
Mathematica to take
the max over all possible
events is going to be difficult.
All right.
So the total variation
has some properties.
So let's keep on the
board the definition that
involves, say, the densities.
So think Gaussian in your mind.
And you have two Gaussians,
one with mean theta
and one with mean theta prime.
And I'm looking at the total
variation between those two
guys.
So if I look at P theta minus--
sorry.
TV between P theta and
P theta prime, this
is equal to 1/2 of the integral
between f theta, f theta prime.
And when I don't write it--
so I don't write the
X, dx but it's there.
And then I integrate over E.
So what is this
thing doing for me?
It's just saying,
well, if I have-- so
think of two Gaussians.
For example, I have one that's
here and one that's here.
So this is let's say f
theta, f theta prime.
This guy is doing what?
It's computing the absolute
value of the difference
between f and f theta prime.
You can check for yourself
that graphically, this I
can represent as an area
not under the curve,
but between the curves.
So this is this guy.
Now, this guy is really the
integral of the absolute value.
So this thing here,
this area, this
is 2 times the total variation.
The scaling 1/2
really doesn't matter.
It's just if I want to have
an actual correspondence
between the maximum and the
other guy, I have to do this.
So this is what it looks like.
So we have this definition.
And so we have a couple of
properties that come into this.
The first one is
that it's symmetric.
TV of P theta and
P theta prime is
the same as the TV between
P theta prime and P theta.
Well, that's pretty obvious
from this definition.
I just flip those two,
I get the same number.
It's actually also true
if I take the maximum.
Those things are completely
symmetric in theta and theta
prime.
You can just flip them.
It's non-negative.
Is that clear to everyone that
this thing is non-negative?
I integrate an absolute
value, so this thing
is going to give me some
non-negative number.
And so if I integrate
this non-negative number,
it's going to be a
non-negative number.
The fact also that
it's an area tells me
that it's going to
be non-negative.
The nice thing is that if
TV is equal to zero, then
the two distributions, the two
probabilities are the same.
That means that for
every A, P theta of A
is equal to P theta
prime of A. Now,
there's two ways to see that.
The first one is to say
that if this integral is
equal to 0, that means
that for almost all X,
f theta is equal
to f theta prime.
The only way I can integrate
a non-negative and get 0
is that it's 0 pretty
much everywhere.
And so what it means is
that the two densities
have to be the same
pretty much everywhere,
which means that the
distributions are the same.
But this is not really the
way you want to do this,
because you have
to understand what
pretty much everywhere means--
which I should really
say almost everywhere.
That's the formal
way of saying it.
But let's go to
this definition--
which is gone.
Yeah.
That's the one here.
The max of those two guys, if
this maximum is equal to 0--
I have a maximum of non-negative
numbers, their absolute values.
Their maximum is
equal to 0, well,
they better be all equal
to 0, because if one is not
equal to 0, then the
maximum is not equal to 0.
So those two guys,
for those two things
to be-- for the maximum
to be equal to 0,
then each of the
individual absolute values
have to be equal to 0, which
means that the probability here
is equal to this probability
here for every event A.
So those two things--
this is nice, right?
That's called definiteness.
The total variation equal
to 0 implies that P theta
is equal to P theta prime.
So that's really some
notion of distance, right?
That's what we want.
If this thing
being small implied
that P theta could be all
over the place compared
to P theta prime, that
would not help very much.
Now, there's also the
triangle inequality
that follows immediately
from the triangle
inequality inside this guy.
If I squeeze in some f
theta prime prime in there,
I'm going to use the
triangle inequality
and get the triangle
inequality for the whole thing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The fact that
you need two definitions
of the [INAUDIBLE],,
is it something
obvious or is it complete?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
I'll do it for you now.
So let's just prove that
those two things are actually
giving me the same definition.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm actually going
to start with the second one.
And I'm going to write--
I'm going to start with
the density version.
But as an exercise, you can
do it for the PMF version
if you prefer.
So I'm going to start
with the fact that f--
so I'm going to write f of g so
I don't have to write f and g.
So think of this as being f sub
theta, and think of this guy
as being f sub theta prime.
I just don't want to have to
write indices all the time.
So I'm going to start with
this thing, the integral of f
of X minus g of X dx.
The first thing I'm going to do
is this is an absolute value,
so either the number in the
absolute value is positive
and I actually kept it
like that, or it's negative
and I flipped its sign.
So let's just split
between those two cases.
So this thing is equal
to 1/2 the integral of--
so let me actually
write the set A star as
being the set of X's such that
f of X is larger than g of X.
So that's the set on
which the difference is
going to be positive
or the difference is
going to be negative.
So this, again,
is equivalent to f
of X minus g of X is positive.
OK.
Everybody agrees?
So this is the set
I'm interested in.
So now I'm going to split
my integral into two parts,
in A, A star, so on A
star, f is larger than g,
so the absolute value is
just the difference itself.
So here I put parenthesis
rather than absolute value.
And then I have plus 1/2 of
the integral on the complement.
What are you guys used to to
write the complement, to the C
or the bar?
To the C?
And so here on the complement,
then f is less than g,
so this is actually really
g of X minus f of X, dx.
Everybody's with me here?
So I just said--
I mean, those are just
rewriting what the definition
of the absolute value is.
OK.
So now there's nice things
that I know about f and g.
And the two nice things is that
the integral of f is equal to 1
and the integral
of g is equal to 1.
This implies that the integral
of f minus g is equal to what?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 0.
And so now that
means that if I want
to just go from the integral
here on A complement
to the integral on A--
or on A star, complement
to the integral of A star,
I just have to flip the sign.
So that implies that
an integral on A star
complement of g
of X minus f of X,
dx, this is simply equal
to the integral on A star
of f of X minus g of X, dx.
All right.
So now this guy becomes
this guy over there.
So I have 1/2 of this
plus 1/2 of the same guy,
so that means that 1/2 half
of the integral between of f
minus g absolute value--
so that was my
original definition,
this thing is actually equal
to the integral on A star
of f of X minus g of X, dx.
And this is simply
equal to P of A star--
so say Pf of A start
minus Pg of A star.
Which one is larger
than the other one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It is.
Just look at this board.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: What?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
The first one has
to be larger, because
this thing is actually
equal to a non-negative number.
So now I have this absolute
value of two things,
and so I'm closer to
the actual definition.
But I still need to show
you that this thing is
the maximum value.
So this is definitely at
most the maximum over A of Pf
of A minus Pg of A.
That's certainly true.
Right?
We agree with this?
Because this is just
for one specific A,
and I'm bounding it by the
maximum over all possible A.
So that's clearly true.
So now I have to go
the other way around.
I have to show you that the max
is actually this guy, A star.
So why would that be true?
Well, let's just inspect
this thing over there.
So we want to show
that if I take
any other A in this integral
than this guy A star,
it's actually got to
decrease its value.
So we have this function.
I'm going to call
this function delta.
And what we have
is-- so let's say
this function looks like this.
Now it's the difference
between two densities.
It doesn't have to
integrate-- it doesn't
have to be non-negative.
But it certainly has
to integrate to 0.
And so now I take this thing.
And the A star, what
is the set A star here?
The set A star is the set
over which the function
delta is non-negative.
So that's just the definition.
A star was the set over
which f minus g was positive,
and f minus g was
just called delta.
So what it means is that
what I'm really integrating
is delta on this set.
So it's this area
under the curve,
just on the positive things.
Agreed?
So now let's just make some
tiny variations around this guy.
If I take A to be
larger than A star--
so let me add, for
example, this part here.
That means that when
I compute my integral,
I'm removing this
area under the curve.
It's negative.
The integral here is negative.
So if I start adding something
to A, the value goes lower.
If I start removing something
from A, like say this guy,
I'm actually removing this
value from the integral.
So there's no way.
I'm actually stuck.
This A star is the one
that actually maximizes
the integral of this function.
So we used the fact
that for any function,
say delta, the integral
over A of delta
is less than the integral
over the set of X's
such that delta of X is
non-negative of delta of X, dx.
And that's an obvious
fact, just by picture, say.
And that's true for all A. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
could you use
like a portion under the
axis as like less than
or equal to the
portion above the axis?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's actually equal.
We know that the
integral of f minus g--
the integral of delta is 0.
So there's actually exactly
the same area above and below.
But yeah, you're right.
You could go to
the extreme cases.
You're right.
No.
It's actually still be
true, even if there was--
if this was a constant,
that would still be true.
Here, I never use the fact that
the integral is equal to 0.
I could shift this function by
1 so that the integral of delta
is equal to 1,
and it would still
be true that it's maximized
when I take A to be
the set where it's positive.
Just need to make sure that
there is someplace where it is,
but that's about it.
Of course, we used this before,
when we made this thing.
But just the last
argument, this last fact
does not require that.
All right.
So now we have this notion of--
I need the--
OK.
So we have this
notion of distance
between probability measures.
I mean, these things
are exactly what--
if I were to be in a formal
math class and I said,
here are the axioms that
a distance should satisfy,
those are exactly those things.
If it's not
satisfying this thing,
it's called pseudo-distance or
quasi-distance or just metric
or nothing at all, honestly.
So it's a distance.
It's symmetric,
non-negative, equal to 0,
if and only if the two
arguments are equal, then
it satisfies the
triangle inequality.
And so that means that we have
this actual total variation
distance between
probability distributions.
And here is now a statistical
strategy to implement our goal.
Remember, our goal
was to spit out
a theta hat, which was
close such that P theta
hat was close to P theta star.
So hopefully, we were trying
to minimize the total variation
distance between P theta
hat and P theta star.
Now, we cannot do that, because
just by this fact, this slide,
if we wanted to do that
directly, we would just take--
well, let's take theta hat
equals theta star and that will
give me the value 0.
And that's the minimum
possible value we can take.
The problem is
that we don't know
what the total variation is to
something that we don't know.
We know how to compute total
variations if I give you
the two arguments.
But here, one of the
arguments is not known.
P theta star is not known to
us, so we need to estimate it.
And so here is the strategy.
Just build an estimator
of the total variation
distance between P
theta and P theta star
for all candidate theta,
all possible theta
in capital theta.
Now, if this is a good estimate,
then when I minimize it,
I should get something
that's close to P theta star.
So here's the strategy.
This is my function
that maps theta
to the total variation between
P theta and P theta star.
I know it's minimized
at theta star.
That's definitely TV of P--
and the value here, the y-axis
should say 0.
And so I don't know
this guy, so I'm
going to estimate it
by some estimator that
comes from my data.
Hopefully, the more data I have,
the better this estimator is.
And I'm going to try to
minimize this estimator now.
And if the two things are
close, then the minima
should be close.
That's a pretty good
estimation strategy.
The problem is that
it's very unclear
how you would build
this estimator of TV,
of the Total Variation.
So building
estimators, as I said,
typically consists in replacing
expectations by averages.
But there's no simple way of
expressing the total variation
distance as the
expectations with respect
to theta star of anything.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to move from
total variation distance
to another notion of
distance that sort of has
the same properties
and the same feeling
and the same motivations as
the total variation distance.
But for this guy, we
will be able to build
an estimate for it,
because it's actually
going to be of the form
expectation of something.
And we're going to
be able to replace
the expectation by an average
and then minimize this average.
So this surrogate for
total variation distance
is actually called the
Kullback-Leibler divergence.
And why we call it divergence
is because it's actually
not a distance.
It's not going to be
symmetric to start with.
So this Kullback-Leibler
or even KL divergence--
I will just refer to it as KL--
is actually just
more convenient.
But it has some roots coming
from information theory, which
I will not delve into.
But if any of you is
actually a Core 6 student,
I'm sure you've
seen that in some--
I don't know-- course that
has any content on information
theory.
All right.
So the KL divergence between two
probability measures, P theta
and P theta prime--
and here, as I said, it's not
going to be the symmetric,
so it's very important
for you to specify
which order you say it is,
between P theta and P theta
prime.
It's different from saying
between P theta prime and P
theta.
And so we denote it by KL.
And so remember, before we had
either the sum or the integral
of 1/2 of the distance--
absolute value of the distance
between the PMFs and 1/2
of the absolute values
of the distances between the
probability density functions.
And then we replace
this absolute value
of the distance divided by
2 by this weird function.
This function is P
theta, log P theta,
divided by P theta prime.
That's the function.
That's a weird function.
OK.
So this was what we had.
That's the TV.
And the KL, if I use the
same notation, f and g,
is integral of f of X, log
of f of X over g of X, dx.
It's a bit different.
And I go from discrete to
continuous using an integral.
Everybody can read this.
Everybody's fine with this.
Is there any uncertainty about
the actual definition here?
So here I go straight
to the definition,
which is just
plugging the functions
into some integral and compute.
So I don't bother with
maxima or anything.
I mean, there is
something like that,
but it's certainly not as
natural as the total variation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The total
variation, [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yes, just because it's
hard to build anything
from total variation,
because I don't know it.
So it's very difficult.
But if you can actually--
and even computing it
between two Gaussians,
just try it for yourself.
And please stop doing it
after at most six minutes,
because you won't
be able to do it.
And so it's just very
hard to manipulate,
like this integral of
absolute values of differences
between probability
density function, at least
for the probability
density functions
we're used to manipulate
is actually a nightmare.
And so people prefer KL,
because for the Gaussian,
this is going to be theta
minus theta prime squared.
And then we're
going to be happy.
And so those things are
much easier to manipulate.
But it's really--
the total variation
is telling you how
far in the worst case
the two probabilities can be.
This is really the
intrinsic notion
of closeness between
probabilities.
So that's really the
one-- if we could,
that's the one we
would go after.
Sometimes people will
compute them numerically,
so that they can say, oh, here's
the total variation distance I
have between those two things.
And then you actually
know that that
means they are close, because
the absolute value-- if I tell
you total variation is
0.01, like we did here,
it has a very specific meaning.
If I tell you the KL
divergence is 0.01,
it's not clear what it means.
OK.
So what are the properties?
The KL divergence between
P theta and P theta prime
is different from the KL
divergence between P theta
prime and P theta in general.
Of course, in general,
because if theta
is equal to theta prime,
then this certainly is true.
So there's cases
when it's not true.
The KL divergence
is non-negative.
Who knows the Jensen's
inequality here?
That should be a subset
of the people who
raised their hand when I asked
what a convex function is.
All right.
So you know what
Jensen's inequality is.
This is Jensen's-- the
proof is just one step
Jensen's inequality, which
we will not go into details.
But that's basically
an inequality
involving expectation
of a convex function
of a random variable compared
to the convex function
of the expectation
of a random variable.
If you know Jensen,
have fun and prove it.
What's really nice is that
if the KL is equal to 0,
then the two distributions
are the same.
And that's something
we're looking for.
Everything else we're
happy to throw out.
And actually, if
you pay attention,
we're actually really
throwing out everything else.
So they're not symmetric.
It does satisfy the triangle
inequality in general.
But it's non-negative and
it's 0 if and only if the two
distributions are the same.
And that's all we care about.
And that's what we call
a divergence rather than
a distance, and divergence will
be enough for our purposes.
And actually, this
asymmetry, the fact
that it's not flipping--
the first time I saw it,
I was just annoyed.
I was like, can we
just like, I don't
know, take the average
of the KL between P theta
and P theta prime and P
theta prime and P theta,
you would think maybe
you could do this.
You just symmatrize it by just
taking the average of the two
possible values it can take.
The problem is that this will
still not satisfy the triangle
inequality.
And there's no way basically
to turn it into something
that is a distance.
But the divergence is doing
a pretty good thing for us.
And this is what will allow us
to estimate it and basically
overcome what we could not
do with the total variation.
So the first thing
that you want to notice
is the total
variation distance--
the KL divergence,
sorry, is actually
an expectation of something.
Look at what it is here.
It's the integral of some
function against a density.
That's exactly the definition
of an expectation, right?
So this is the expectation
of this particular function
with respect to this density f.
So in particular, if I call
this is density f-- if I say,
I want the true distribution
to be the first argument,
this is an expectation
with respect
to the true distribution from
which my data is actually
drawn of the log of this ratio.
So ha ha.
I'm a statistician.
Now I have an expectation.
I can replace it by an
average, because I have data
from this distribution.
And I could actually replace
the expectation by an average
and try to minimize here.
The problem is that--
actually the star here should
be in front of the theta,
not of the P, right?
That's P theta star,
not P star theta.
But here, I still
cannot compute it,
because I have this P
theta star that shows up.
I don't know what it is.
And that's now where
the log plays a role.
If you actually pay
attention, I said
you can use Jensen to
prove all this stuff.
You could actually replace the
log by any concave function.
That would be f divergent.
That's called an f divergence.
But the log itself is a
very, very specific property,
which allows us to say
that the log of the ratio
is the ratio of the log.
Now, this thing here
does not depend on theta.
If I think of this KL divergence
as a function of theta,
then the first part is
actually a constant.
If I change theta, this thing
is never going to change.
It depends only on theta star.
So if I look at
this function KL--
so if I look at the
function, theta maps
to KL P theta
star, P theta, it's
of the form expectation
with respect to theta star,
log of P theta star
of X. And then I
have minus expectation with
respect to theta star of log
of P theta of x.
Now as I said, this thing
here, this second expectation
is a function of theta.
When theta changes, this
thing is going to change.
And that's a good thing.
We want something that reflects
how close theta and theta
star are.
But this thing is
not going to change.
This is a fixed value.
Actually, it's the negative
entropy of P theta star.
And if you've
heard of KL, you've
probably heard of entropy.
And that's what-- it's
basically minus the entropy.
And that's a quantity that
just depends on theta star.
But it's just the number.
I could compute this
number if I told
you this is n theta star 1.
You could compute this.
So now I'm going
to try to minimize
the estimate of this function.
And minimizing a function or
a function plus a constant
is the same thing.
I'm just shifting the
function here or here,
but it's the same minimizer.
OK.
So the function that maps
theta to KL of P theta star
to P theta is of the form
constant minus this expectation
of a log of P theta.
Everybody agrees?
Are there any
questions about this?
remarks, including I
have no idea what's
happening right now?
OK.
We're good?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
actually employing this method,
how do you know which theta
to use as theta star and which
isn't?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So this is
not a method just yet, right?
I'm just describing to
you what the KL divergence
between two distributions is.
If you really wanted
to compute it,
you would need to know
what P theta star is
and what P theta is.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: And so here,
I'm just saying at some point,
we still-- so here, you see--
so now let's move onto one step.
I don't know expectation
of theta star.
But I have data that comes
from distribution P theta star.
So the expectation by
the law of large numbers
should be close to the average.
And so what I'm doing
is I'm replacing any--
I can actually-- this is a very
standard estimation method.
You write something as an
expectation with respect
to the data-generating
process of some function.
And then you replace this by
the average of this function.
And the law of large
numbers tells me
that those two quantities
should actually be close.
Now, it doesn't mean that's
going to be the end of the day,
right.
When we did Xn bar, that
was the end of the day.
We had an expectation.
We replaced it by an average.
And then we were gone.
But here, we still
have to do something,
because this is not
telling me what theta is.
Now I still have to
minimize this average.
So this is now my candidate
estimator for KL, KL hat.
And that's the one
where I said, well, it's
going to be of the
form of constant.
And this constant, I don't know.
You're right.
I have no idea what
this constant is.
It depends on P theta star.
But then I have minus something
that I can completely compute.
If you give me data and theta,
I can compute this entire thing.
And now what I claim is that
the minimizer of f or f plus--
f of X or f of X plus
4 are the same thing,
or say 4 plus f of
X. I'm just shifting
the plot of my
function up and down,
but the minimizer stays
exactly where it is.
If I have a function--
so now I have a
function of theta.
This is KL hat of P
theta star, P theta.
And it's of the form--
it's a function like this.
I don't know where
this function is.
It might very well be this
function or this function.
Every time it's a translation
on the y-axis of all these guys.
And the value that I translated
by depends on theta star.
I don't know what it is.
But what I claim is that the
minimizer is always this guy,
regardless of what the value is.
OK?
So when I say constant, it's a
constant with respect to theta.
It's an unknown constant.
But it's with respect to theta,
so without loss of generality,
I can assume that this
constant is 0 for my purposes,
or 25 if you prefer.
All right.
So we'll just keep going
on this property next time.
And we'll see how from
here we can move on to--
the likelihood is actually going
to come out of this formula.
Thanks.